any outside risks and uh challenges but
inside our country we have to be more
effective and work not um uh according
uh today's agenda but tomorrow's agenda
too uh what i would like to say
first it's the main thing that you want
you have to understand
is happening it's
it's something that
now we didn't we were not given any
other chances to act otherwise yeah
and i would say and i'm really surprised
we we didn't move any further not even
not even an inch
i want to underline and emphasize that
this is this is not what was
[Music]
we live again
and we we're ready to what's happening
at the moment um as to sanctions and
restrictions
uh in the end of the day uh i just want
to say
something like it's very important what
i'm gonna say
i want to
russia becomes
a part of the world
russia is a part of we don't we don't do
any harm to this system of world
economy which we are a part of
[Music]
and we
are there
and i think our partners should
understand that and
do not push us outside
of this system
uh even even of course uh some
restrictions will happen because of the
police politics and all the rest and i
want to uh appeal to you and ask you
please understand what's happening
with solidarity with the government
and we will maintain our economy
uh
industry
and uh
workplaces
from on behalf of the government and uh
the authorities
of course i i see that uh
we will give you good conditions we
provide you more freedom
we will provide you more freedom for
your entrepreneurial activities
of course in
certain in certain brackets
because we need to have some
predictability from
from the government but we expect the
the predictability on the part of
business
clearly we cannot
uh
foresee
you are absolutely right to expect
some predictability some understandable
and stable
predictability and most of all we have
to keep a constant contact react acutely
to any uh changes and we have to correct
all the mistakes and
the incorporate together and i want to
thank you for all your work
and
i hope that
we will be working in new conditions i
don't think they are totally new
but we will be working
in solidarity and no less effective